do you feel you made a mistake skipping
the Film Festival's just to go directly
to the audience with amateur I mean it's
been what two months I guess since
you've posted the short online do you
wish you'd gone the film festival route
or was this your whole plan to just post
it online yeah that's something that I
will wonder about and you know it's one
of the challenges of filmmaking is that
one movie comes out and you think it's
really good and no one wins no one would
to see it meanwhile some you know a lot
of people are going to see something
else and you don't know whether it's the
strategy of it why that is you know
there's one of the harder things about
filmmaking is that the success of your
your project is predicated on so many
different things and there's no real way
to go back and change it so you know to
me the releasing a short online for free
the success of that is predicated on
half you how do we reach the sports
world and the film launch couldn't have
gone better you know on day one we're on
the front page of indieWIRE filmmaker
magazine short of the week directors
notes
it's a Vimeo staff pick you know I think
that the strategy of releasing it for
free online instead of going to
festivals was sound but that does open
you up to the vagaries of the news cycle
and so the day I released it the day I
premiered it was when the Boston
Marathon bombings happened and that's a
that's not only a huge news story as it
should be but it's also a sports related
story so any website that I was reaching
out to that I had an initial contact
with suddenly they had you know many
many many stories to do for weeks about
this in the fourth you know the
following week Jason Collins became the
first NBA player to come out of the
closet
another huge news story as it should be
meanwhile the NBA playoffs are going on
at the same time so I think you know I
have a lot of experience with strategy
and planning and all these things and I
think my strategy was sound but no
matter what your strategy is things will
always happen that make it you know
there are a lot of moving parts and so I
was trying to get out in front of the
NBA Playoffs but that window
when the Boston Marathon bombings
happened and I can't complain about that
because obviously a lot of people have
really really terrible things that
happened as a result of that but in your
over in this little filmmaking world and
you're like I can't complain but this
you know this thing really made my
release my little film release more
challenging so you know I don't don't
necessarily know that it's online
release only vs. Film Festival's the
short is still gonna be playing at some
film festivals despite the fact that's
online and I think you know I think
there are a lot of talking points there
as far as some festivals have a policy
that they will play stuff that played
online and some have a policy that they
won't but there's a lot of gray area as
far as you know what's your exposure
have been online you need to take it
down during the time it's playing at the
festival you know are you playing out a
competition because you are online there
are a lot of things that I think for me
is worth it just to explore those those
issues from my perspective firsthand
based on experience and I'll be sharing
that what I find on no film school but
you know the jury is still out as far as
the strategy of releasing a short who
we've been able to reach you know we're
gonna be releasing it on YouTube with
sort of a different strategy as kind of
a second wave and you know I'm still
talking to a number of websites that I
hope it will end up on and you know
ultimately my approach was making the
short in general as opposed to releasing
it online was that it's gonna be a great
thing for the feature regardless of how
it turns out and who sees it because for
me it's a proof of concept and it's
getting on the set and working at a
certain pace and finding good crew
members and just you know the on set
reps of making a movie in this genre but
I think there are a lot of different
approaches you could take with a short
you know one would be okay you make it
you hold it back if you're trying to
raise fun right fund raising you
approach investors privately with a
screening it's good they feel special
they're invested in making this happen
because they feel like they've had
special access that would be one way of
doing it you know the other is to submit
the film festivals and wait and
hopefully you know you play a
prestigious festival maybe you even win
some award and that kind of validation
allows you to then go pitch to investors
and while it's still not online I think
I'll always wonder about these different
approaches but there's really no way of
knowing beforehand oh this is right oh
this is wrong this will work this won't
and for me ever since I got started I've
always felt that you know there's a
place for drama and for quality content
online and it's always been a goal of
mine so it just made sense to go with
this approach especially as we've been
in pre-production on manchild and
development for so long that waiting for
a festival or doing these things behind
closed doors it was only gonna you know
make the delay longer so I you know I
wanted to rush and I wanted to put it
out there
and have people see it you know it's a
work I'm extremely proud of and so that
was ultimately kind of the the the
decision maker as far as you know
putting it online it's a short prequel
so you want people to watch it and feel
like they want to see more and in that
sense the more people that see it the
better in terms of dealing with your
plan of action and then the world acts
of God whatever things coming in and
taking over and we've heard so many
people say well I've launched a crowd
put funding campaign but then this came
this crowdfunding campaign or this world
event happened it sounds like your plan
is just to keep going not complain and
just proceed as normal or are there
times that maybe people should pull back
and say you know what this is probably
the wrong time to do this you know I
think when you're when you're sort of
spread thin and you're overworked and
you're just pushing forward yourself
there is no really pulling back you know
I would love to have a number of
consultants and we have a meeting and
everyone strategizes and we break and we
come back a week from now and then we
play
other thing but you know it's me it's me
pushing the rock up the hill and so I
feel like any time I you know let go of
the rock it's just rolling back down so
for me yeah just the momentum of it and
keep pushing and have the attitude that
this is gonna happen with or without
whoever's involvement you know whoever
you're meeting with next you're making
it and hopefully they want to be on
board and if not you're making it anyway
that's kind of the approach I have and
you know I guess there'll be plenty of
time in the future to take meetings and
pause and strategize and you know take
our time with it but but you know I'm
not I'm not letting go of that that rock
at this point
you